all right hi everyone my name is Jon
Niese and I'm looking forward to have a
chance to talk with you all about our
work on version 3 of the plotly Python
library so they'll quickly introduce
myself I did my undergraduate studies so
I'm sure it's no turn it on though
best thing this one on alright give its
try so yeah I did my undergraduate
studies in physics and mathematics at
Millersville University my graduate work
in computer science at Johns Hopkins
University I now work as a data
scientist and software developer at the
Johns Hopkins Applied Physics Laboratory
and one of my areas of interest has been
working on applying what I see as some
of the best of the PI data ecosystem
just of our challenging analysis
problems and PI data DC actually
displayed a a role in that process about
two years ago I guess exactly two years
ago I attended a PI did you see my first
data science related conference and I
had a really great experience talking
with some of the maintainer so different
projects and it's very really inspired
to kind of get more involved in my own
learning and in the different
communities and I was so inspired I got
involved in some open source projects I
did some contributions with last two
years to pandas and ask and then and
then plotly and over the past four
months ago I actually became the
maintainer and lead developer of the
poly Python library and I'll talk in a
minute about how that fits in the rest
of the poly
ecosystem so goal is to give you sort of
a whirlwind tour of what we've been up
to about this past four months and I
started though with some background so
partly Jas is the Java Script is a
JavaScript David realization library
it's based on d3 and and WebGL and it
supports a really wide range of
visualization types it covers a lot of
financial statistical Geographic use
cases and even some advanced
three-dimensional use cases the library
was initially developed by the company
Pali Technologies Incorporated it was
part of their mission a part of their
commercial visual Asian products but it
was open sourced in 2015 under the MIT
license and it's been an active
development on
github ever since so just to be clear up
front
everything I'm gonna show you today is
based entirely on or is entirely open
source technology it's self-contained it
works offline it doesn't require an
account and you can use all of this your
own servers there is integration with
some of the poly cloud services that's
all optional and not what I'm talking
about today
alright so poly jest is a declarative
library and in this case that means that
every plot is fully defined by a JSON
specification so you don't need to know
about the order of operations to
represent a plot it's represented
declared a book by this JSON
specification in addition to that
declared representation it has a really
nice API for updating plots after
they've been created and then for
receiving callback events in response to
user interaction things like hover and
selection and click like those kinds of
things now the Python library so poly
dot pi is the Python library with the
job of generating these JSON
specifications for plots so before
version 3 this was a one-way one-time
thing the Python library would build up
this JSON representation and be passed
across to a JavaScript live the drip
library and that'll be displayed either
in a notebook output cell duper notebook
or it could be displayed in a standalone
HTML file or uploaded to one of the
floppy cloud accounts and there wasn't a
way to get the information back from the
JavaScript side back to Python there
wasn't a way to get access to the
interaction events like selection
information so that's where the I PI
widgets framework comes into play so I
buy widgets and the Jupiter widgets
assigned on the front end provides a
really powerful instead of building
blocks for supporting the shuwei a
two-way synchronization of properties
between the Python back-end and the
JavaScript front-end and so what I
started with is I worked on creating a
new iPad widget Python library for
Paulie Jas initially I did this on kind
of the outside as a as an experiment and
then I showed this as a prototype to
some of the poly folks and they're
really excited about it and then I work
with them to get it integrated
two polygons PI upstream and that
integration then became version 3 of the
falli Python library and that's what we
released back in July I believe was so
that's as far as I'm going to go into
the technical details of how this
synchronization how its updates work I
did write a paper for Syfy this past
summer so if you're interested in more
about how this works or interested in
doing this for another library how
writing on this kind of widgets
wrappered to get this synchronization
can check out this this paper there at
the summer for free sources sack by 2018
all right so here's it's a quick summary
of some of the features that were
introduced in version 3 can go through
these and then do some demos and then
show you talk about what's happened
since then so the biggest piece is the
SyFy widgets integration and this is
made it possible to display plots in the
notebook and then update them in place
after they are created and we have a new
imperative property assignment API for
doing that there's now a great auto
completion and inland documentation
across the entire graph objects API and
there's also a much more robust property
validation and the error messages are
really more precise and a lot more
helpful and thanks to the Wi-Fi witness
integration now it is possible to get
information back from the JavaScript
side so we can support registering
Python functions to be called in
response to interaction events like
clicking and hovering on your plots
finally this version takes advantage of
some of the nice optimizations in the
widgets protocol so that when you're
working with large arrays that are now
transferred in binary format across from
Python JavaScript so you can get much
faster interaction with working with
arrays like up to a like through scatter
plots like up to a million points is is
tractable now alright so I'm gonna jump
into a couple of demos live code let's
see
okay so this is one of the many cars
data sets this one has information about
efficiency fuel efficiency horsepower
torque for a data set around 5,000
vehicles made between 2009 2012 and then
to make this a little interesting I did
some simple web scraping to pull down
the first google image search result for
each of these descriptions so here's
what it came up with for those 2012
chevy camaro coupe i would make my first
figure now is this is gonna be a torque
versus miles per gallon scatterplot and
the start off i'll show you the
declarative nature of applaud up high by
creating this figure with a single trace
to start with so you can always define
the entire figure in the constructor
every property that Palio depay supports
you can put in the constructor and get
the whole thing at once and now I'll
show you later on how you can
iteratively update them as well so this
figure widget class is a new class we
introduced in version 3 and it is itself
a type I widget so what that means is
you when you dump it out to the the
notebook its display representation is
the plot itself so you don't need to use
a special function to display the plot
it renders itself in the notebook all
right but I forgot to label anything on
this figure so I'm going to take care of
that I could go back up to the
constructor and add some new layout
properties it set the labels then
regenerate the plot and look at it again
I don't show you the the new property
assignment API and how you can do that
with a already constructed plot so here
I have a figure object and now I can
show you how get completion across this
entire object hierarchy of properties
that are supported so here except
completion on title I can use a shift
tab to pull up the documentation string
for that property here I can see that
title is a string it need to specify it
as a number or a string or a number and
then I can assign to it I'll sign to it
torque and fuel efficiency
and then immediately the plot is updated
with the new title this happens
automatically there's no extra step of
like pushing the change to the notebook
this is like detected in the assignment
and an updated right away and while I
was looking at that completion menu I
noticed there's another property are
called title flan so I wanna see I can
use that to change the size of the title
so I'll title font to your completion
again and then look for size here I can
use shift tab to find the description
this is the the property that sets the
font size
I'd like it be a little bit larger than
the default but to do that I need to
kind of understand what the default is
and in past versions of polygon pie and
a lot of flying libraries it's it's not
always easy to find out what the default
the faults were that were chosen for you
and how you can adjust from that but
with this two-way synchronization we're
actually bringing the properties that
were chosen by the JavaScript library
back to Python so you can just access
this property and see that the default
value that was chosen was 17 so I can
pull that up to make informed decision
of how I want to change it and that's a
22 and now I have a larger larger title
alright and then as we're fine change
the font family to drop well alright so
you can see that's getting a little bit
cumbersome to scroll up and down between
the codes I'm doing update the plot and
the figure so I want to show you another
of my favorite features about Jupiter
lab is that I can right-click on this
notebook output cell and pick up the
option for creating a new view for this
output cell this will open up a new tab
and Jupiter lab that has only this
output cell and I can drag this around
and place it arrange it where I want in
the notebook this is a fully responsive
I can resize thing it's got the
arrangement the way I want because this
is built on iPad widgets these views are
actually two views of the same data
model so I can do things like pan and
one and zoom and the other these are
linked together so I can work
interactively on this view to the side
as I scroll down with my notebook
without having to scroll up and down but
the plots still there so you still get
the full linear reproducible work
of your your final notebook so it's a
nice I think best of both worlds from
there and now I have the side view I'll
set the x axis titles property
assignment
notice that updated right away hope the
same thing for the y axis and then just
to show again that you stay in a sink
I'll scroll up and see that both the x
axis and y axis titles were made in both
both places alright so the labels
looking good and I was a little more of
the data itself so if i zoom in on a
chunk of this data set I'll see that the
points are quantized thank these
discrete jumps in the miles per gallon
and the torque as well oh so I can't
really tell the debt the real density of
this distribution of weather
how much over plotting is going on it's
one way to work with this is to apply a
slight random jitter to these points and
I can do that whoops first I'll grab a
reference to the scatter trace scatter
is the first trace in this figure and
then with that scatter trace reference I
can update the x and y values with the
property assignment and again
immediately I get this change I can see
the jitter applied to the plot and with
that I can tell that I do have an over
plotting problem I have this always
solid regions where I'm not able to
understand what the density isn't how
relative to other regions in the dataset
so one way to work around this over
plotting problem is to work add an
opacity to these points so I can go back
to my scatter trace use completion to
find the marker and then look for the
opacity and check the documentation
strings see that the opacity needs to be
a number it needs between 0 and 1 and
then I can evaluate it to see what the
default capacity it was chosen for me by
poly doc Jas and that was a VIP a CT of
one's a fully fully opaque and then I
can assign to it all of the sine of zero
point two to it drop that down and that
that helps a good bit I can start to see
the denser regions more easily and I
look like the size as well I'm gonna
shrink the size a little bit so I can
evaluate vid default size see that was
six and then I drop that down to four
all right now what if I had not read the
documentation with this things and I
just tried to assign the passage
50 here I'll see what the new more
precise error messages look like so here
it I'm not only detecting that the
number that the value we need to be a
number but also even evaluating the
range itself so if I got an error
message let me through the this passes
invalid because I need to be a number
between 0 and 1 or here's the case of
I'm evaluating a enumeration property so
this hover mode is an enumeration
property with a few valid values I'll
try to set it to nearest and get this
error message telling me that it's an
immigration value these are the valid
values XY closest and false so I can
immediately understand that I've just
remembered the property name so I can
copy this and change it to closest
that's what I meant from record color
there are a lot of ways to specify
colors and the named CSS colors are
supported so I'm gonna try a set this to
color of these points to fuchsia and I
get this error message telling me all
the valid ways to specify colors and as
I scroll down I can see that
I didn't spell fuchsia properly so I'll
copy their correct spelling and then if
you update and then I get the weight
right away and then the Vitis I don't
want to use keisha after all you can
always go back to the default values by
assigning none to the property that was
was overwritten
so I assign the more color back to none
I'll go back to the default value that
Polly Jess chose all right so another
way a helpful way to get a handle on
distribution density is to use the
histogram 2d contour trace this is
another trace type that probably comes
with and I can do that add it to the
existing figure so I can look through
all of these supported trace types by
triggering completion on the figure
object and with add underscore and
here's the list of all the trace types
that Polly supports long list here I can
get Alec set completion on histogram 2d
contour shift tab to pull up the
documentation and I can read about this
trace I can reintroduce R in this case I
want to just pass it the same x and y
values I gave to the scatter plot so
it'll show me a density contour plot for
those same points and there we go I can
look at this contour trace object and
and explore its properties interactively
so I'd like to change the color
scale or look at what color scales are
supported so I trigger documentation on
the color scale property I'll get a list
of the ways to specify color scales so
here's a list of name Clark scales you
can use or you can specify custom one so
let me grab one of these named ones
I'll grab hot the Clark scale updates
that's a bit dark so I can want to flip
it around so that the white region is a
little low density region and then I can
see a nice compliment to the points to
have this is dual set of information
okay that's up the hover info to skip
that way I'm not getting extra hover
info on the contour trace I'll only get
the hover info on the points which is
what I want in this case and I mean I
like this a lot like having the ability
to see the outliers and see the
distribution and see the smooth all at
the same time but to do this you really
need to have the opacity and list point
size dialed in so you can make sense of
both so here gonna make some adjustments
and yeah that's a little bit too opaque
a little smaller and I can kind of
fiddle with this until I get a view that
I feel like represents the let's me see
the information that I want but when you
find yourself doing this kind of thing
where you're adjusting properties and
running a cell and trying something else
running it again that's a good clue that
you could use a Chi widgets to help you
with this so I'm going to write a little
function here that performs this same
operation just called set opacity it
inputs the ax passing in size I want and
performs the assignment and then I can
wrap that in a call to the interactive
function for my PI widgets I pass in my
setup asset e function and then the
range of values that like it'll sweep
over so visit the range of opacity is
the range of sizes I wanna be all sweep
over and then this produces a new widget
like at this little control panel and I
can use now to interactively in the
notebook as I'm looking at my data to
adjust the properties so as I'm zooming
in or panning around I can just have
this off to the side to help me
understand and see this a dataset more
easily now let me adjust the properties
on the sliders Nick a little wider and
there we go all right
so next I want to look at the outliers
so this dataset has a nice tight
distribution with outliers kind of on
both sides in particular or some downs
or in this heel region that I want to
look at you change to pass it again so I
get a better look at them so like I
understand what these points are one
helpful way to start this is I can
adjust the tooltip by default the
tooltip gives you the information about
the x and y properties that you gave to
the trace but I can customize that and
I'm going to customize it to display the
car ID from the original data set so now
when I hover over I'll see the name of
the vehicle that are these outliers and
that's really helpful but there are a
bunch of other properties that were in
the data set that are more than just the
name I'd like to see all of them and
have a way to scan through this data and
see all the properties the outliers to
different make sense of what's going on
oh one way to do that is to use a an
HTML Wi-Fi widget so here I'm going to
use another widget called HTML I'm
initialize it with a simple HTML string
to show you what what it looks like how
it again displays itself as a ml
representation but then I want to
override that with an HTML table
representation of all of the points that
I'm hovering over to do that I create a
new function called hover function and
I'm gonna register that function with
the scatter trace when you use the on
hover callback mechanism this is saying
whenever a hover event happens on this
trace run this function for me so I'm
gonna run the flower 500 function well
the function we'll do is grab the
indices of the points that were involved
in the hover event it'll take those
indices find the location in the data
frame and then convert that to HTML this
is all pandas expression to look up the
row in the data frame and make an HTML
table out of it I'll assign the HTML
table to the HTML widget and then I'll
show what happens so now when I hover I
can see all of the properties I can see
the index of the point and all the
properties of the points that I'm
looking at
and then looked at same thing for the
image let's now use an image widget to
display again this start out with the
2012 Camaro coupe and then I'm gonna
slightly update my hover function to now
do the HTML table update as before but
then update the image widget as well
with the same same point so now if I run
this update I've overridden the old
hover function with this new one and now
my hover I get to see all the vehicle
types and looks like there's a lot of
conversion bands down here at the same
time my HTML table is also still
updating so this is I mean you can keep
these widget components spread out
throughout the notebook and just pull
them off to the side when you need them
depending on what you're using them for
but it's also easy to pull them out all
together into a little notebook
dashboard at the end this too here I'm
just using the container objects from
Wi-Fi which it's a CH box and D box let
you stack widgets together and make a
larger collection out of them and there
we go I have this little end notebook
dashboard that I can use to explore this
data set change properties and and the
goal here is that this wasn't a large
like software development effort this is
just part of the analysis process this
isn't a dashboard I want to use for
every data set this is what I wanted to
use to look at this particular one and
what I think is exciting is that once
you learn a few of these hi widget
conventions and how to update figures
you can make these in the process of
just looking at data as part of an
analysis workflow I think that's a
pretty powerful workflow to move into
the next one I want to show you is a
example of responding to data selection
so here is a another data set this is
the slice from the Gapminder a life
expectancy GDP per capita data set this
is a slice from year 1982 so I started
off which is a scatter plot life
expectancy for countries GDP per capita
on the y axis in log scale and then
markers are sized with an area
proportional to the population of the
other countries and this whole tip shows
me the names of the countries
then also make a choropleth this is
another flatly built-in poly trace type
where I have a different region colored
in for each country here I've
initialized both of these to be colored
in gray and then I'm going to install a
selection callback so here I'm for each
trace that's guided racing the
choropleth I'm going to install this
callback to be run when data is selected
and that will update the coloring of
both traces and update the selection
information which will highlight the
newly colored areas now run that and
then put that in a little sack dashboard
again and now I can do investigation of
regions of this space so I'm going to
start with selecting this area of high
income high life expectancy countries
and I can see where those are
distributed across the world or if I did
the opposite I look at the lower income
lower life expectancy countries and see
where those are distributed across the
world or the quarter plus Impala
actually also supports election so I can
select the countries across the
continent and see their distribution in
this life expectancy GDP per capita
space so this was again you saw all the
code to wire this up and you can do your
own custom interactions based on these
on these events you have a lot of
flexibility and how you want to build up
these little control panels to help you
explore your data set ok I'll jump back
to my slides
and talk about what's happened since
version 3 so simply real severe version
3 here are some other things been
working on so partly Jas has loved for a
long time supported latech typesetting
in in figures it's using mathjax under
the hood the same engine that's that's
doing the math the low-tech typesetting
for the Jupiter notebook but it hasn't
worked well before in the notebook
because there's a lot of complications
going on with using mathjax for
different things at the same time global
state that took a lot of work to sort
through but we have sore throat now so
you can use the tech typesetting on your
labels inside the duper notebook and if
I have time I'll show you that looks
like in a few minutes we've had a
theming support so now it's possible to
configure what you want the default
properties to be across a particular
figure or across all the figures in your
session so we're shipping with a
collection of predefined themes but then
it's also possible for you to find your
own themes and they have a lot of
options in addition to like setting the
colors and font styles you can also do
things like setting default labels on
figures so you can put like confidential
and top and bottom or you could put a
watermark a company logo on the side so
you can set these up to if you'd like
build them up you put them in a Python
package and pork them and then all the
figures do you make in that session we
could go to follow that that theme the
next moment to talk about is a
programmatic image export so this is a
really complicated problem for
JavaScript based visualization libraries
how to convert your nice interactive
diagram into a high quality static image
because you need a browser to do the
rendering somewhere and browsers can't
write to files directly so there's a lot
of considerations here the solution that
the poly team that came up with I'm
really excited about it's based on
electron so we're using a standalone
electronics executable to do the
rendering into an image and we've been
able to package that electron program
called Orca using both Conda and NPM so
you can Conda install all the
dependencies you need to do static image
export and it doesn't rely on webdriver
it doesn't rely on a system
browser being installed it's all
self-contained and we've added a
collection of new trace types so here is
a bar polar trace type as a bar bar
chart in polar coordinates and this is
also very interactive as supports things
like zooming you can rotate stuff to
help you hone in on the information
you're looking at and this complements
existing support we already have for
polar scatter plots and polar line
charts there's a new diagram that called
a parallel categories diagram this is a
visualization for multi-dimensional
categorical data sets and you can think
about it as a discrete or a categorical
analog to the parallel coordinates
diagram where your columns represent
dimensions and then the rectangles in
the columns represent categorical states
and the height of these rectangles lets
you see the relative frequency of the
different combinations of states in in
your dataset there's been we've added a
3d cone chart this is what you can use
to represent three-dimensional vector
fields zoom in here and see this is a
again WebGL accelerated 3d chart type
that lets you show these directionality
of the vector field and then finally a
3d stream tube chart type this is a
really nice way to look at continuous
flow spaces you can look at these stream
tubes understanding the flow of a
continuous space and these two new 3d
chart types they complement the existing
support that we have already for WebGL
accelerated 3d scatter traces three
lines three surfaces 3d meshes and 3d
ribbon charts ribbon surfaces alright I
have a couple minutes left I'm gonna
jump into these last two demos quick so
here's what the themes support looks
like so I'll create the same use the
same data set to create a another bubble
chart here I've used a separate trace
type or separate race for each of the
continents so I got a different color
cycle color cycle through different
Contin
this is the default colors that Polly
jeaious uses and I can look at this a
templates object now to see a list of
the available named templates that come
pre-loaded with with Polly PI so we have
a seaborne inspired template we have a
ggplot2 inspired template and then a
collection of new original templates
based on some of the colors we like for
for Polly stuff so this is the Polly
template it uses some of the gray
background this is a new color palette
of points for the different races flatly
white uses the white background but the
still our color palette and then any one
here is a dark theme fan SuperLab comes
a really nice dark theme but always
bothers me looking at white plots on a
dark theme so we've added a poly dark
template type but I think looks really
nice when you're working and the
SuperLab dark theme all right suspect
back to standard theme you can mix and
match your templates so presentation is
the name of another template that is
included and this has the job of
increasing the font size of all the
elements of the plot it also increases
the line width of line traces this can
be combined with other theme types so I
can combine presentation with a plot
like theme I should be above and get
both of these applied so now I have the
font size increase then they have the
styling I wanted from the poly
presentation plot not the theme and then
one last one is this X grid off theme
but has the job of only removing the X
gridlines so I can combine these three
together and get a cleaner looking
scatterplot where I don't have the x
squared lines added as well and then
static image export so all you need to
do to get to add static image export is
to run a condo command like this or
you're installing the poly or Co package
and the PS util package and once you've
done that you can use
the right image function from the Palio
package - I'll put these images so there
I just output these six the same plot
into six different image formats
actually what that looks like over here
in it right in Jupiter lab we have
raster formats for PNG JPEG vector
formats for SVG and an even PDF so I can
zoom in on its PDF and you can see this
is a true vector format image alright
last thing I'll show you a quick example
of the tech support Oh
before that I can show you this is how
you would set a default theme to use
across your entire session so if you set
this template default value to the name
of the theme this will now be
automatically added apply it to anything
or you create if you don't override the
theme later so I did this once at the
top of the session and then now when I
create a new figure it'll automatically
use the new polythene so to use latech
in plotly you surround strings with
dollar signs and everything inside then
is treated as latekka it's passed the
mathjax method access this thing bruises
an SVG and we do a lot of subtle things
to put it in right place and then this
also works with the figure widget
support so now I can update labels
interactively and they just work with
otech and it's also works with some of
the export options so now I can output
this figure with the effect type setting
to a standalone HTML file and I can then
email this to someone and have the
typesetting preserved and finally this
also works with the image export so here
I'm going to export this figure to a
vector PDF form save it to disk I'll
open up let's like figure PDF and I have
a figure with a theme with low-tech
typesetting that is for
a vector formatted in this figure so
this is a publication quality static
image that was made from our interactive
visualization library and that is our
setup of highlights so if you want to
learn more and come talk to me of course
but I've also pinned some links on my
Twitter account if you look at my
account on John and me on Twitter I have
a post pin with a bunch of links to
we've done that several blog posts the
3.0 announcement post goes into pretty a
lot of detail and the where I showed you
in the first demo with the validation
and the widget aspects the paper from
the proceedings if you want to know more
about how I fight widgets works
underneath and how we used it to get
this synchronization worked out there's
a whole post on how the static image
export works with the Orkut integration
this whole post on how the themes
integration works then there's a link
there to the main poly Python
documentation and I want to call out
finally two other poly open-source
products that are related to the poly up
I first is - so followed up PI and the
iPad widget approached I showed you is
really great for doing the exploratory
phase and for quickly making widgets
quickly making things to help you look
at your information in detail once you
know how you want to present information
and how you want to explore this type of
data - gives you the tools to create
really sophisticated web applications
based on more sophisticated widget types
that's based on Reax you have a much
larger suite of components that you have
access to you have full access to the
HTML structure you have full XSS CSS so
you can really have pretty unbounded
flexibility and making web applications
still totally on Python without writing
any any JavaScript if you're interested
in that Chelsea has a talk and I'm a
couple hours on - and then the trooper
lab chart editor is a new project we've
just released that takes the graphical
chart editor that Polly has used and
it's on line of products for awhile
there's a new version of that editor was
released as
open source editor and now we've
integrated that into Jupiter lab so you
can use that directly from the super lab
file menu to open figures in the
graphical editor edit them make changes
them out annotations and save them back
out again in a GUI workflow so it richer
than that you can talk to me or you can
check out that that project as well and
with that I'll take any questions yes
yeah they're on a github on my account I
think that link is also pinned on on
Twitter kind of if not all I'll add it
up there yes it works but the but the 3d
stuff is rendered on the GPU so those
become raster embeddings inside the
inside the figure so you don't get the
true vector scaling for those yeah it
goes into and it goes into vector
I mean SPG you can put PNG stuff inside
it and that's kind of how it goes for
the stuff it's rendered on the GPU it
retains the hover and click part that
the callbacks that require Python or not
won't be maintained so you can still set
up the interactions for displaying
zooming and panning and hovering over
things and getting the tooltips all
works but Python code won't be there
all right well come find me if you have
any other questions or want to tell
about ideas but thanks for your time
[Applause]